bonsoir et bienvenue dans le cette fille
de sport l'émission dédiée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
football après sa belle épopée en coupe
de france élimination cinquième tour le
club de mort pas joué ce week-end en
championnat contre vallée 78 est mort
d'asia ont fait match nul au stade du
bout des clos les détails dans cette
édition
le boxeur évinois rachid achoui
affrontera ce samedi dominique seux loi
pour la finale du critérium de
compétition qui sera organisé en
normandie nous le recevrons sur ce
plateau dans quelques minutes avec son
entraîneur jean guy farrugia basket coup
de projecteur à suivre sur le sigle ici
et là un camp d'entraînement créé en
2012 et qui peut permettre à des
basketteurs du département d'intégrer
les prestigieuses universités
américaines
et puis influents des missions tour
d'horizon de l'actualité sportive du
département
il sera notamment question du trail des
sept hameaux mais également des
résultats de françois pervis ligne
montrent un aux championnats d'europe
sur piste
l'équipe de mort pas retrouvé ce
dimanche le chemin du championnat
excellence contre vallée 78 une semaine
seulement après son élimination en coupe
de france sur leur pelouse du stade du
bout des clots la mort pas un n'ont pas
pu faire mieux qu'un match nul d'un but
partout
romain respini à pour le montage du
retour au quotidien pour mort palais
vers jouer ce dimanche en championnat
excellence après leur épopée en coupe de
france ils leur défaite au 5e tour
contre boulogne billancourt au stade du
bout des clos les norvégiens n'ont pu
faire mieux qu'un match nul d'un but
partout contre vallée 78 une équipe qui
pointe pourtant la 10e place du
classement
on n'est pas rentré dedans dans mon
propre un bond et a tiré un bon état
d'esprit je sais pas où nos têtes
étaient mais c'était pas dans son pardon
championnat donc enfin leurs coûts
continuent à embaucher voilà on a fait
une belle une belle aventure en coupe de
france maintenant on savait qu'il
fallait qu'on se reconcentre pour le
championnat et voilà on est on l'a dit
avant le match sur l'a 10 à la mi temps
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore fait assez
les efforts pour pour gagner ce match à
la maison quoi dans ce match haché et
son rythme le défenseur central et
capitaine fabien perrot a réalisé une
partie convaincante solide dans les airs
et dans ses interventions le moc pas ya
également égalisé juste avant la mi
temps avec un but plein d'opportunisme
jaffer un but en renard des surfaces
c'est pas trop mon style mais boyard ya
un coup franc qui est dévié au premier
poteau et puis j'arrive bien à la suivre
jeu là tout juste du bout du pied ce
qu'il faut donc voilà après j'aurais
préféré que que les copains marque
d'autres buts pour qu'on puisse
remporter ce match mais voilà c'est
toujours toujours un plaisir qu'à
marquer dans un match au classement mort
paille dernier du championnat excellence
avec deux matches en retard
prochaine rencontre pour les verts le
dimanche 1er novembre au contre le
chesnay un derby qu'il faudra remporter
pour le pas sont moches toujours en
football c'était le match qu'il ne
fallait pas manquer pour les
nostalgiques de la coupe du monde 98
les variétés club de france composée
notamment de laurent blanc didier
deschamps et christian karembeu a foulé
la pelouse du stade léo lagrange de
poissy pour un match amical et fonds
récoltés ont été reversés à des
associations patrick jacques de dixmude
pour les images match de gala hier soir
au stade léo lagrange de poissy les
anciens champions du monde 98
laurent blanc didier deschamps fabien
barthez et christian karembeu ont
rechaussé les crampons à l'occasion d'un
match exhibition entre le variétés club
de france et la sncf
le match s'est soldé par une victoire du
variétés 4 à 2 avec un triplé du
brésilien sonny anderson
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu un précédent
ici à poissy avec de telles stars prenez
simplement dit deschamps
champion du monde vainqueur de la ligue
des champions avec marseille vainqueur
de la coupe d'europe avec l'équipe de la
juventus de turin
c'est juste exceptionnel ça fait plaisir
de se retrouver et il y avait du monde
tout est parfait vous êtes senti comment
vous sur le terrain
vieillissant pour ce match amical plus
de 2500 spectateurs sont venus garnir
les tribunes
sa résolution qu on a eu ce qu'on a vu
en replay je ne t'ai pas encore né à ce
moment là qu'on voudrait revoir l'équipe
de france en ce moment aussi et les voir
en vrai ça fait bizarre
franchement ça me fait chaud au coeur de
voir le genre 98 qui viennent jouer sur
nos stades sur le pelouse
sachant que je suis choquée et se fit un
plaisir et ça fait chaud au coeur à tous
les pisciacais de france un match pour
la bonne cause les faux récoltés pendant
la manifestation seront reversés à
l'association urma parrainée par laurent
blanc et l'association plus de vie
présidée par bernadette chirac
ça me fait chaud au coeur vous savez on
a en a du mal actuellement à trouver de
l'argent vous en doutez c'est une crise
économique
bon les gens les gens moins d'argent à
donner aux autres et puis ceux qui en
ont besoin quelquefois il en donne pas
au total la manifestation a permis de
récolter ses 1300 euros pour les deux
associations
après une large page de football on
quitte le rectangle vert pour les rings
de boxe
le boxeur évinois rachida achoui dans
les starting blocks le sportif licencié
à saint quentin en yvelines affrontera
ce samedi dominique ceaux loire
normandie à l'occasion de la finale du
critérium national des poids moyens pour
nous parler de ce qu'on va nous recevons
sur ce plateau rachid h oui mais
également son entraîneur tandis
farruggia bonsoir rachid à quelques
jours de l'événement
la question est simple est-ce que vous
êtes prêts après en forme
enfin on vendra jamais envie comme
jamais et vous êtes entraîné comment du
coup sûr ces derniers mois pour être
salée avec le fait est que le boulot
c'est le défaut c'est pas évident donc
fait j'essaie de gérer avec les horaires
je travaille donc j'essaie de
m'entraîner à peu près deux fois par
jour tanguy est ce qui est vraiment dans
la forme de sa vie
rachid je pense que dont il est en
pleine forme pour ce combat là y'a pas
de problème mais je sais qu'ils peuvent
faire mieux il peut faire mais c'est à
dire je je vise au tueur ce titre hui au
dessus de ce site soit là et est ce que
est ce que vous connaissez bien son
adversaire de dominique j'ai vu quelques
images de
de lui on l'a vu un petit peu en amateur
maintenant je connais rachid jeu un mois
d'un accident parce qu'on n'est pas au
foot sur un coup tout arrive en moins
d'un accident je pense que rachida
toutes ses chansons vous rejoignez votre
coach si vous avez regardé des matches
de votre adversaire dont j'avais vu
boxer il ya un an et demi au championnat
de france
donc j'ai boxé aussi même même jour
c'est un bon boxeur mais je pense je
pense être au-dessus largement c'est un
sérieux concurrent ou c'est où c'est un
boxeur on va dire que vous allez sur
passer facilement c'est un seul compte
le rend vraiment concurrents dans un
mois je le prends je prends ossalois
final voilà son final d'un tournoi quand
même 20 national donc je prends au
sérieux
je suis entraîné comme si c'était le
match des deux villes mois de ma vie
abbas et la fin ce sera le combat le
plus important quand même ma carrière
moi j'aime carrière en vigueur et
quelles sont les recettes pour remporter
la victoire sur cette rencontre
les roussettes moi je dirais pas j'irai
du sérieux du serveur entraînements
simplement on n'a pas de ça que c'est un
sport difficile avec pépin sacrifice
donc je pense que tant content qu'on
s'entraîne correctement on peut on
parler de londres et sur le ring vous
allez vous avez boxer d'une certaine
façon vous avez une approche tactique de
la rencontre je vais boxer comme comme
d'habitude peut être comme je sais boxer
donc non pas à pas spécialement de deux
tacles mise en place pour ce combat mais
on essaiera s'adapter s'il tanguy
comment comment rachid doit boxer lors
de ce combat là je ne dirai rien parce
que je sais que l'adversaire peut avoir
les images mais vous avez établi une
tactique a quand même pouvoir forcément
loin de ça il a une technique et c'est
plus ou moins préparé même si on n'a pas
discuté mais il ya une chose qui est et
qui prévoit là et moi je pense pas je
dis moi je devrais peut-être pas le dire
parce que c'est pas bien mais je pense
pas qu'ils finissent le combat
l'adversaire vous pensez que ça pèse
finir par un ko je pense voilà la seule
fois où il a gagné au bois rachid c lin
d'oeil à boxer une gastro voilà moi je
c'est rare que je dis ça mais j'ai
confiance
voilà j'ai confiance je pense que c'est
sans vouloir le mettre la grosse tête
mais je pense que c'est l'avenir de la
france
le boxeur que la france attend rachid je
boxe en poids moyens quelles sont les
particularités de cette discipline
est-ce qu'il faut être plus mobile
rapporté spectateurs qui ne connaît pas
forcément la catégorie chanteur il est
vrai moyen ça va ça va plus vite que les
poids lourds
sa frappe un peu moins mais sa frappe
voilà donc c'est un c'est une
il faut que ça soit rapide et bien se
servir des gens bien et vous sentez que
sur ce combat là ça va être peut-être la
rapidité qui peut jouer la rapidité la
vitamine a sur ce moment là ça va être
tout qui va jouer parce que rachid il a
quand même un peu d'expérience il a fait
quelques combats internationaux avec moi
il a fait comme en quarts de finale aux
france que l'adversaire n'a pas fait ça
et
bon il a gagné des adversaires
qu'ils ont moins d'expérience que les
adversaires en boxer rachid alors parce
que rachidi la boxe et des mecs de 6,7
combat au championnat et il les a battus
et même avec la manière donc je pense
que je pense que les adversaires le plus
dur était du côté de l'aja d'origine
rachid est ce que ce combat peut être un
palier vraiment dans votre carrière vous
êtes encore jeune est ce que ce combat
arrive à point nommé
clairement oui comme disait tanguy c'est
quand même une fille à l'aide
internationale
donc qui pourrait m'ouvrir des portes
qui sait mais je prends comme un sérieux
de ce combat quand il ya des projets
derrière justement tandis que ce type de
combat peu qu'on soit une carrière c'est
un peu aussi un peu la ralentir là où la
houle a lancé voilà c'est quand on a un
titre on est toujours plus respectées et
ont des raisons que voilà j'ai déjà le
téléphone arabe
on va dire ça va vite et rachid a
commencé déjà sur une réputation
donc moi je ne sais ce que je veux c'est
quand même le protéger au maximum et on
est en pourparlers avec d'autres
personnes pour lancer cette valeur donc
vous êtes optimiste un sens qu'on va
tout à fait même chose pour vous rachid
est optimiste qui me faisait jouer la
gagne avant de se quitter nous allons
parler d'un boxeur je pense que vous
connaissez bien tous les deux c'est tony
hawk à qui vient d'être sacré champion
du monde amateur des super lourds la
semaine dernière à boxer qui est
originaire des mureaux aspect qui lui
permet d'être qualifié directement pour
les jeux olympiques de rio est ce que la
performance de tony yoka vous surprendre
on lit la question laissant surprendre
dans wii donc dans le sens
moi je les ai connus en boxe éducative
j'ai vu sa progression au fur et à
mesure on sait qu'il ya c'est quelqu'un
qui est sérieux puisqu'il est déjà venu
à mettre les gants chez nous à tout ça
on voit on voit la progression qu'il a
maintenant
je pense qu'il a lui aussi la russie
grâce à son sérieux quand même un
minimum il a su m il a su faire avec son
père parce que c'est son père qui
l'entraînent a su faire les la part des
choses pour progresser au bon moment la
preuve est là aujourd'hui c'est la
fierté de la france
rachid même chose pour nous ça ne vous
surprend absolument pas les résultats
tony yoka enfin moi je ne connais pas
tellement non plus c'est pas ma
catégorie mais franchement je suis la
fille station voix c'est non non c'est
ça pousse la boxe est peut-être dans une
autre dimension s'il en a pas mal parlé
dans sûrement dans tout ce qui est
journaux et c est ce qu on fait ça alors
là ça met en valeur la mort à la boxe et
moi je sais que le meilleur quoi parler
jouant à rio en 2016 je souhaite
vraiment de de réussir surtout que qui
est du département plus donc tant mieux
peut-être vous sera sa place un jour
peut-être on joue peut-être pas
guillaume et moi en tout cas moi en tout
cas une au niveau médiatique à jesper
pourquoi pas les copeaux qui sait
j'espère merci à tous les délais de
passer sur ce plateau bon courage à vous
rachid pour ce match de saïd donc la
finale est programmée ce samedi en
normandie on suivra votre combat avec
attention et on en reparlera dans le 7-8
sport la semaine prochaine en passe
maintenant au rugby
un tournoi de rugby féminin était
programmée mercredi après midi au stade
de porchefontaine de versailles pour
cette troisième édition une soixantaine
de filles originaires des yvelines ont
joué des coudes dans les mêlées pour
remporter la victoire
mélanie poker pour les matchs mais les
redoublements de passes plaquage ce
mercredi ses joueuses de rugby en herbe
n'ont pas ménagé leurs efforts au stade
de porsche antenne de versailles pour la
troisième année consécutive un tournoi
était organisé par le rugby-club de la
ville et les associations sportives de
collèges des yvelines objectif
développer cette discipline chez les
filles transpole ans ce sont en fait les
professeurs qui demande plus de dates de
compétition pour les filles car on sait
que la pratique ça aide les filles à a
mieux joué
donc ce sont les professeurs qui sont
qui nous qui nous sollicitent en fait
pour faire des tournois et nous à
versailles on est ouvert sur le
développement du rugby féminin les
collèges de bois d'arcy de carrières
sous poissy du chéné de noisy le roi et
de magnanville ont participé à ce
tournoi
au total une soixantaine de jeunes âgés
de 11 à 15 ans se sont inscrits pour la
compétition 20 de plus que l'année
dernière
je pense que la coupe du monde à aider
un peu plus cette année justement a
rassemblé plus de filles au niveau des
associations sportives
après généralement le rugby on y vient
pour l'esprit camaraderie donc entre
copines
et puis pour le jeu c'est un jeu qui est
assez dynamique de cleo jeune fille
avant mes frères et ses raisons mais
après j'ai pris leur exemple et j'ai vu
c'était bien c'est bien de jouer avec
des filles ça change de jeu avec des
garçons c'est mieux que les filles
fassent quand même du rugby parce que
c'est pas excusable mans sport de brutes
moi j'ai comparé à ce qu'on peut dire
dans la catégorie des minimes les
barbarians une équipe composée de
joueuses de montigny-le-bretonneux de
versailles et de couflens remporter la
victoire
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
quatrième édition le cibi sieller un
camp de basket créé en 2012 est organisé
pendant l'été à los angeles est en plein
essor
la structure a permis un jeune minime en
tain de partir aux etats-unis à
cleveland pour nous parler de ce camp
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
fondateur corneille et trois membres
yves binois du sib icl et hugo rafael et
alexandre bonsoir corneille quand avez
vous eu l'idée de créer ce camp tout au
long de ma carrière que je suis un
ancien joueur de basket pour me
présenter rapidement
donc ça a été grande et 1012 1 c'est ça
c'est ça en 2012 - mais l'idée a germé
au fur et à mesure de ma carrière j'ai
pensé déjà depuis un moment
en tant qu entraîneur de basket j'ai vu
les manquements on va dire au sein des
des clubs ou des formations qui m'a
donné l'idée de monter ce qu'en 2012 et
ce quand justement ça permet de régler
certaines carences peut-être de la
formation à la française
je pourrais vous répondre par oui non
oui dans le sens où
la formation française est une très
bonne formation elle permet de former
des élites on connaît tous par le biais
de de l'insep notamment où des
différents pôles etc
sauf qu'il ya certains joueurs qui n'ont
pas été repérés jeunes non versés par
ces pôles et qui sont selon moi un peu
délaissé et mon but à moi c'est de
repérer ces joueurs là qui n'ont pas été
repérés par d'autres grandes structures
et de les faire germer et concrètement
ça se passe comment états unis
expliquez-nous un petit peu leur
quotidien à bas leur quotidien c'est de
leur montrer pour ceux qui sont dans des
clubs on va dire classique donc avec
deux entraînements voire trois
entraînements maximum par semaine c'est
déjà du bon niveau c'est de leur montrer
que on s'entraîne beaucoup donc quatre à
six heures d'entraînement par jour de la
préparation physique régulière de lever
lever tôt le matin avec une bonne
hygiène de vie
donc c'est de leur montrer que la vie de
sportif de haut niveau pour ceux qui
veulent tenter l'aventuré s'est pas non
plus de tout repos
et pourquoi avoir ciblé il est 13 22 ans
c'est justement ce cette idée de
progression peut-être chez eux qui vous
intéressent
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait parce
que comme j'ai dit si on veut
en france si on veut terminer en
professionnel entre guillemets il faut
déjà avoir été repérés avant l'âge de 12
ans donc si on n'a pas été repéré à 12
ans il est très difficile de pouvoir
jouer entre fait de percer dans le
milieu professionnel
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé ma
catégorie à 13 ans car pour ceux qui
n'ont pas été repérés avant
c'est un chemin de croix qui commence
pour eux donc c'est à partir de là et
jusqu'à 22 ans car après 22 ans il est
difficile d'avoir une formation qui nous
permet d'aller en professionnels
eux-mêmes l'université commencé à fermer
ses portes après 22 ans hugo qu'est ce
qui vous a attiré dans ce camp avez vous
connu déjà je lui connu puisque on fait
ce qu'on aime qui me coachait donc avec
raph et lettonie et en fait ça m'a
vraiment attiré parce que ça me permet
de découvrir une culture donc des états
unis qui n'est pas du tout pareil
et quand et nous avons dû et nous a
proposé le projet en moi j'ai accepté en
tout cas et j'ai découvert le camp et
tous les entraînements et comme disait l
hygiène de vie et étant même chose
bonbons afin la même chose mais moi j'ai
entendu les états unis sa masse un vote
soucis plus puis à tout montrer beaucoup
plus que je m'entraîne d'anormal et
avoir des entraînements aux états unis
pour jouer sur un parquet qui est qui et
de là-bas et découvrir les états unis
puisque j'ai toujours voulu y aller
vous êtes fan de basket mais les fans de
basket des bn liothier la nba
tout ce qui va avec du coup c'est un
rêve d'aller là bas oui c'était un rêve
c'est un rêve et le tout premier voyage
va acheter content d'y aller avec mes
amis voilà ça s'est bien passé
encore là il vous en parlais tout à
l'heure ce camp est quand même assez
difficile quand même il faut il faut il
faut travailler c'est pas c'est pas pour
aller en vacances on va pas en vacances
aux etats unis c'est vraiment pour
travailler
en effet il faut pas oui voilà qu'il
faut qu'on voit qu'on mélange sait pas
quand de vacances je peins centre aéré
c'est un camp de basket avec des
journées comme jeudi 6h de basket
notamment il ya une journée quand même
qui est assez typique et une journée qui
se passe à manhattan beach sur une dune
avec une pente assez vertigineuse si on
n'est pas préparé physiquement et
mentalement on risque de mal finir c'est
cette journée d'entraînement
donc oui c'est assez difficile mais eux
ils vous en parleront mieux que moi je
pense que les y ont vécu
ils peuvent s'y peut plus être capable
de vous dire si c'est difficile ou pas
avec ces enregistrements est-ce que
c'est difficile parce que en france on
n'est pas habitué à ce genre
d'entraînement
on habitait juste des entraînements
normaux et là on nous dit on va monter
une scène d'une avec énormément de
difficultés et puis c'est quand même
assez éprouvant il faut le faire une
fois dans sa vie c'est très difficile
beau papa forcément la dune éloquent en
général oui le camp et en plus les
coaches oumma pourrons nous pousser dans
nouveau pousser dans nos limites au
maximum est de toujours nous dépasser et
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais
après quand on a fini le l'effort on est
on est content d'avoir fait avoir il ya
un jeune qui a réussi on en parlait il
ya tout à l'heure c'est tommy c'est gore
ces jeunes ils mentent et intégrez une
équipe de basket à cleveland
nous l'avons interviewé juste avant son
départ on écoute je réalisais pas
forcément j'ai beau début fontainemelon
blague
je n'ai jamais peur je ne crois pas même
jusqu'à jusqu'à la semaine dernière je
réalisais pas encore là c'est dans les
derniers jours je me dis ah ouais c'est
dans deux jours et là je me dis c'est
demain c'est là que je me réalise
vraiment compris ce que wade veut partir
et je vais jouer toujours voulu jouer
aux états unis même pendant moi je
m'étais dit que ouais c'est impossible à
je devais un peu vieux pour jouer
tats-unis donc je vais rester en france
mais c'est venu comme ça donc après je
me dis que ma peau jamais perdre espoir
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
raphaël je sais que c'est l'un de vos
meilleurs amis
est ce que ça vous fait fort ce plaisir
de le voir partir là bas
et est ce que ça vous donne envie vous
aussi de rejoindre oui vachement ça me
fait plaisir je lui ai dis franchement
je suis content pour toi et j'espère que
l'année prochaine il faut être rejoints
de grâce au civil si elle est et
j'espère que ça va bien se passer pour
lui est qui et qui va continuer à
travailler dur labeur hugo c'est un
moteur aussi pour vous de voir tommy à
réussir comme ça les aléas qui blanc
peut-être s'entraîner avant lebron james
le fameux le fameux bipied alors un
billet je les ai vus avant son départ et
je l'appelais dont j'ai souhaité le
meilleur qui s'entraîne au maximum et
qui qu'ils puissent on va dire percée et
ouais vraiment ça me donne envie aux 1
vraiment n'importe quel niveau j'ai
vraiment ça me donne vraiment envie de
pouvoir dépasser encore plus c'est de
pouvoir essayer de monter un projet
corneille et le civis et elle est pour
aussi de partir aussi
corneille est ce que tommy c'est un cas
unique au 6 bis si elle est où est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya d'autres
pépites qui sont en train de grandir au
sein de votre votre structure pour moi
pour moi il y a
il ya beaucoup d'autres pépites il
suffit de prendre le temps de les polir
pour voir quelles qu'elles ont beaucoup
de valeur
ne serait-ce que ces deux joueurs ici
présents raphaël et hugo qui que je
connais maintenant depuis trois ans qui
pour moi sont des joueurs qui vont
suivre le chemin de tommy et le but
c'est qu'ils aillent tous jouer aux
états unis où également qu'ils
apprennent des leçons de vie par exemple
ouais ou voilà deux qui progressent dans
leurs baskets et de leurs baskets
non c'est un projet éducatif entourent
lucie vicié les c'est pas purement
basket pour apprendre je tends comme
lady d'une leçon de vie basée sur la
rigueur que le travail que dans la vie
quand on veut quelque chose il faut
travailler c'est pas des choses qui
arrivent tout seul donc voilà et qu'il
faut être aussi ouvert d'esprit pour
aller découvrir ce qui a aussi autour de
nous pour apprendre de ce qu'il ya
autour de nous en gardant ce conte
là d'où on vient bien évidemment et que
ce mélange des deux cultures forme
justement pour moi une troisième culture
qui est celle de la réussite
merci à vous captez de passer sur le
plateau dernière question collègues
comment fait-on pour s'inscrire à ce
camp ça se passe comment c'est très
simple vous allez sur le cibi sieller
point fr donc 6 bis y est les eps.fr et
vous allez dans la rubrique réservation
et vous avez tout tout qui a indiqué une
fiche à remplir et envoyer au
secrétariat me reste quelques places
pour voir pour l'année prochaine il va
falloir il va falloir faire vite pour le
premier camp est presque déjà pleins
pouvoirs mais combien alors on emmène 16
par caen pour garder ce qu'être ce
travail qualitatif en fait nous ont fait
pas dans la quantité et ce premier camp
est déjà quasiment plein et les autres
sont déjà en cours de remplissage donc
il faut qu'il fallait vite il faut aller
assez vite
j'espère que le message est passé en
passe maintenant aux autres résultats du
week end
on commence cette page résultats par de
la course à pied le trail des sept
hameaux était organisée ce week-end au
départ de magny les hameaux
au programme deux courses une première
de 27 km une autre de 14 km à travers la
benne la chose avec 98% de chemin dans
les bois avec de la boue et des cailloux
cette année la compétition a fait le
plein 621 coureurs ont pris le départ
des 27 km notre journaliste patrick
jacques de dixmude étaient sur place
pour recueillir les réactions des
participants et organisateurs justement
la course c'est vraiment agréable
d'avoir ce type dans la région est vrai
qu un trail comme ceux ci c'est agréable
en plus vraiment les parcours qu'on va
traverser son départ expérience vraiment
vraiment chouette donc voilà donc quand
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un travail et un
mot j'ai pas hésité je me suis inscrit
on a la chance d'habiter magny les
hameaux dans le parc naturel de els
chevreuse
donc voilà on a tous les paysages qui ce
qu'ils peuvent utilement être un
comment nexus one évidemment pour les
coureurs
non c'est sa première fois que je serai
et ça a créé des chinois de souche et
ici bon j'ai un peu peur parce que là je
vois tout le monde super équipe et moi
pas vraiment je me dis voilà je vais
aller au bout j'ai un peu regardé
rapidement je le répète pourtant plus
qui matent ce qui m'attend mais bon
voilà je me suis quand même entraîné
donc ça va pour la course 27km berthe
engeance de l'équipe de verneuil est
arrivé premier avec un temps de 2 heures
3 minutes et 14 secondes il a devancé de
près de 8 minutes son dauphin benjamin
vigneault
la première féminine juillet thibault a
terminé 56e en 2h33 hameau de cyclisme à
présent ligne montrent un françois
pervis n'a pas brillé pendant les
championnats d'europe sur piste
arrivé à court de forme pour cette
compétition organisée à granges ensuite
en suisse le pistard tricolore a été
éliminée dans les épreuves de vitesse
individuelle dès les seizièmes de finale
vendredi dernier pour jour de son 31e
anniversaire
françois pervis a tout de même rectifié
le tir ce dimanche en terminant à la
seconde place du keirin son épreuve de
prédilection
derrière le tchèque pavel kelemen
pendant ces championnats d'europe la
france a remporté huit médailles dont
une en or avec bryan coquard dans
l'élimination après le cyclisme on passe
au rugby vous étiez des millions de
téléspectateurs devant vos écrans pour
le quart de finale de la coupe du monde
france nouvelle zélande
un match qui s'est soldé par une
humiliation pour le quinze tricolore 62
à 13 et 9 essais encaissés dans cette
rencontre no 2 heavy noah eddy benarous
originaire de trappes et louis picamoles
du chéné n'ont pas pesé bien lourd face
aux redoutables all blacks le xinjiang
louis picamoles a même été sanctionné
d'un carton jaune pour un coup de poing
et deux joueurs vont à présent regagner
leur club le racing métro pour eddy
ménard ou c'est le stade toulousain pour
louis picamoles
on passe au football quatre sur quatre
pour trappe les joueurs de wow china ou
s'ils ont encore réussi un grand match
pour l'emporter contre villepinte ce
week end au stade gilbert chance à clé
trappistes ont été ultra dominateur pour
l'emporter sur le score de 3 buts un
dans leur forteresse au classement
trappe occupe la première place avec
louis et saint leu deux équipes qui ont
également gagné ce week-end un trappe ce
n'est devancé qu'à la différence de buts
par we prochain match ce dimanche 1er
novembre contre sarcelles à l'extérieur
en basket trappe enregistré sa première
victoire de la saison en nationale 3
lors de la 4e journée du championnat les
trappistes
se sont imposés 70 à 62 sur leur parquet
contre bons conseils
ce week-end au classement les ivy noir
est toujours dans les profondeurs de
cette poule d de nationale 3 trappes et
avant dernier du championnat juste
devant son adversaire du jour bons
conseils
c'est la fin se 7 8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78